el Afganistán Aunque la guerra terminó
oficialmente en agosto de 2021 la
violencia no ha parado de golpear a la
población civil según la ONU decenas de
estudiantes murieron en kabul tras un
atentado suicida dirigido a una escuela
privada los equipos de derechos humanos
de la ONU en kabul ayudan a establecer
un registro preciso del ataque a la
escuela en el barrio de jasara las
últimas cifras revelan al menos 35
muertos y 82 heridos la mayoría de las
víctimas son niñas y mujeres jóvenes
ubicada en el oeste de la capital afgana
en un barrio que cuenta con un 95% de
azaharas una minoría Chita la escuela
era una de las pocas que aún acogida a
niñas y niños juntos en aulas
compartidas el atacante logró
infiltrarse mientras los alumnos
presentaban una prueba que ya había un
examen de acceso a la universidad en el
Centro Educativo kajj y la explosión se
produjo dentro del aula donde se
realizaba el el perpetrador detonó su
cinturón de explosivos frente a las
filas ocupadas por niñas lo que explica
que la mayoría de las víctimas fueran
mujeres los menores hombres que se
encontraban en las filas superiores del
aula fueron menos afectados el atentado
aún no ha sido reivindicado pero las
autoridades afganas y extranjeras creen
que la organización estado islámico que
considera herejes a la comunidad azahara
podría ser responsable el 20 de abril
seis personas murieron en explosiones en
una escuela masculina en el mismo barrio
El sábado mujeres y activistas azaras se
manifestaron en kabul para condenar
estos repetidos ataques a La minoría